[Music]
in caught on tape news
submitted by area 51 staff Wow a man's
ring doorbell footage sparks alien
abduction conspiracy theory I feel like
I've seen this wait the rain doorbell
leaves weird artifacts right no I think
he disappears so yeah this story or like
this video went viral with like
conspiracy theories around it and stuff
I like Bobby you have the answer but
it's not fun so let's just go with
conspiracy theories of that's do it yeah
trick me don't tell me you want to
answer that all with my brain the reason
why I'm telling you all have the answers
cuz I if one of you guys know the answer
but I thought if I already know and it's
just like nah let us have fun okay yeah
that's true huh thanks for saving it
you're welcome this is scratching his
ass oh that's an alien right there here
we go what did you see what happened no
no oh oh he just left
oh he beamed out a [ __ ] space it was
a [ __ ] bad that's crazy do that again
yeah play one more time
that fool [ __ ] beamed into space dude
I like how he's like the most normal
[ __ ] too like he's like I I'm
gonna go get some bears that's what it
looks like you know Santa Claus I gotta
go to work that's tight imagine if that
was like a real thing though how [ __ ]
dope it does look like him it does was
that some [ __ ] lighting a firework
and it just flew up I know so he freezes
for a sec right and then the bird flies
by yeah or bad was it like a light like
a car passing by you know how has like
the reflection of the light and they
went up no wasn't a kid play with the
laser pointer playing with the cat in
with this no was it him jacking off
really hard at it shoot he gets invited
to the sky yet okay yeah you have a big
dick if you eat something funny
sometimes your comment goes in the dark
really oh yeah very true
no I'm gonna try it watch your feet okay
see something kind of crazy you don't
know what the food is
oh we have a backlight huh yup your turn
to get annoyed I'll try you module a the
to do that work
okay yeah don't you know they're trying
to babe she has to get laid before that
to happen okay this could be a dry run
practicing your dry yeah my dad calls it
doing homework doing well cuz he called
me the other thing is like hey I just
let you know it's been a year and he
said you guys want to have another kid
and I'm like yeah so dad
yeah he goes well you don't haven't had
the kid is like trying to pretty much
pressure us to have it in the second one
yeah I know I'm just happens when it
happens he goes have you been doing your
homework like have you been doing at
home or grandkids yeah Wow my parents it
was kind of awkward cuz in Vegas now
when I my lip got busted open yeah you
having sex my mom was like well did he
at least finish I mean do you think
there's a chance it could get pregnant
wasn't my mom's her mom yeah and it was
like yeah it was our second time of the
night so like yeah there was already a
first time and she was like okay thank
God yeah come right now mom's like he
didn't finish that time but like it was
right before like it was right after the
first time and she was like okay good
figured you got the first load in good
yeah were you like we were having sex we
were [ __ ] or we were having
intercourse oh we were trying to we were
thinking to make you were trying to make
a baby
oh that's leaving wait or say you're
making a baby and she was like well did
he finish I told her we lose [ __ ] so
does that mean school lied to us cuz we
could bust nuts multiple times in the
cream pies and still not get girls
pregnant but then they make I feel
pretty difficult make it seem like you
could jack off and get a little [ __ ]
pre-cum on your finger and your finger
bang her and then get her pregnant
that's how dangerous they make those are
crazy when you're a teenager that's like
think of your fertility you're like oh
yeah you actually could get pregnant way
faster then well you did yeah your
summers are all slow what's more
important multiple ovulations are lots
of orgasms well actually the more
relaxed the mother is are like that so
easier it is to conceive yeah not
stressed they told me that it's still a
possibility that girls could get
pregnant from anal sex
yeah no no any sort of public skinny
miss sperm like wheat leeks a sperm can
you believe it do some counter and
alright work through a double dipper
like you like to go yeah that's true
yeah I do like to do that cause UTI is
immediately I know well not if the girl
cleans our so first do it in the butt
okay that's on here
she got a lick it off oh my [ __ ] god
the dipstick I think there's more
bacteria in your mouth than in here [ __ ]
so you got poopy [ __ ] nuggets in
there little bacteria your mouth now
mixing with the bacteria your seal your
poopy nuggets or not Daryl that is nasty
that's full of bacteria I'm trying I'm
trying to help you know that isn't bad
he doesn't want it in the book I mean
wait he doesn't want to put it
in the butt doesn't want to get my boss
big reasons my few a way to have his
back he doesn't want anything in his
butt I tried okay
I prefer scientific person did you put
your science head on first you [ __ ] I
mean if she's gonna put something in
your butt why don't you put your side
set up for that my husband had on I'll
sort of make her happy I'll be a good
husband go ahead stick it in there he
couldn't a big good husband make it
happy I wanna make you happy
it would have because I feel like now he
trusts me but right now I feel like I
wasn't really trying hard to trust
there's no trust like I trust her but my
[ __ ] did it you know what it is Bart
you have to wouldn't you trust someone
you relax exactly I would have been
troubling my butt cheeks apart
everything is Lawrence my put cheeks
apart and my [ __ ] was still tight
it's not yeah that's like a trust fall
where you just lean back and enjoy you
really trusted you you could relax you
dad as you felt now he's doing the
[ __ ] damsel in Beatrice that's cool
I think that somewhere inside deep
inside you don't trust doesn't trust you
clincher thank you I thought you had his
back I do maybe I can go to Tony Robbins
seminar nasan why can't I let my
butthole relax what can i express you
[ __ ] but all in all hang up and
listen thank you
yeah please help me well I mean we ended
up talking about Ethel's but we're
talking about we started talking about
this Oh alien [ __ ] what happened you
guys ready for the answer you want yes
play some more
is it provocative is it gonna get the
people going is it a lens flare
it's boring and you are too thick
holding it cuz it's so boring it's a
lens flare so I started to talk about
[ __ ] true let's play my fish you have
[ __ ] in your mind a lot it's the one
tie a cell phone to a kite and they flew
it vertically oh that's a good idea
I think hey video had an artifact on it
right where there's something that
happens in in the motion detection
anyway you know he just got the raw file
and then went on [ __ ] editor or
whatever I can't remember I haven't
I'm sure and then and then he'd like
pause and then he just moved it yeah so
the actual answer is that there was a
technical glitch with the camera and so
he believes that the camera stopped
filming right at the moment he was out
of frame so it looked like he
disappeared
as for the like light going up it's just
the technical glitch
why is he checking back on himself
walking out of the front door you don't
do that ever man reprogrammed him to say
that I think so do you at least sounds
like some NASA [ __ ] it sounds crazy
like a UFO go up on camera in the ISS
weather balloon and they shut the camera
off yeah I always say some [ __ ] like
that technical glitch technical
difficulty [ __ ] yeah they even make
fun of it in the movies yeah all the
aliens though I did not picture an alien
to look like Bob that's going on he can
fly up I think if there are aliens
they're very racist because they only
grab white people well this guy was a
black guy it was black yeah pretty
racist
I see no color maybe Jordan I see no
color guys are getting called out today
you would marvel I can see a racist when
I I know erase what I see what Joe's
like hey aliens of racist pieces what no
how could you not tell yeah we all saw
it I couldn't tell her a nighttime
vision I didn't know either bum just
dumped it on the guy what are you saying
nighttime vision you can't see him cause
he's black this what he looks like this
is like you you're the only race I look
like a black guy too you know
that's not the photo you showed it see
see color let it show you a photo I just
did nap is your gamer is that why no he
was being murdered on skype stop
guessing
put on the video one more time god damn
it my mind is playing tricks on me the
videos a guy's ass I could see [ __ ] you
really can't tell from the video though
okay where's the swag in his walk
I don't say that he beat that for sure
see he should have been walking he
should have been walking like that
apparently I thought his skin was white
dude this dude you said you don't see
color we gotta rewind the video
obviously everyone's white to me cuz
there's colorless Bart and Joe think
that black people walk with the hipster
I didn't say [ __ ] about the hip scab
that's barred by the race he got beamed
up I don't know there with this
explanation he definitely got me I think
so too dude like it's no question looks
white to me was he doing weird [ __ ] now
when he opens his mouth like [ __ ]
music comes out like it picks up radio
signals no well he has no memory of this
[ __ ] thing happening why I think the
real magic here is the Hawaiian
tournament tips trying to save you from
a [ __ ] hole you keep digging I'm
trying to go deep down what I thought
was interesting was why do we even like
how do we even have this video like how
did he know to go back to that no I'll
say that why who checks back on
themselves walking out of that oh good
that NASA I think he got beamed up you
gotta [ __ ] probed and he's like I'm
gonna catch this moment on film and he's
gonna release it and then the government
was like no the government was like you
can't tell the public truth you gotta
say this [ __ ] and then so then he got
paid off and said some other students to
do what do you think the government does
do you think they'll be like well
[ __ ] take your family if you do and
don't never find you again I think they
try with money first
and then I always take the money I don't
even they say anything they just go that
way you technically did to do a
conspiracy corner oh if someone did that
to me I'd be like you're not part of it
we just Sam we beamed this in oh two
three oh [ __ ] they beam them in you
don't even know how to do it bar that
was not it it's two weeks
that's it that's it
wait don't you guys bring them together
I thought I thought half we have okay
let's do it one two three ha ha we're in
that turned into a halt we supposed to
do see you'll never get it you weren't
there hey I think we have to change the
name from conspiracy corner to something
else though that's what I heard but I
kinda want to keep it because it's
funnier okay why well we could talk
because we have some friends that had
that I think it's you actually take your
show I think so Oh ask him next time but
who gets more views coming okay we'll
ask them a perfect yeah so why ask it
will call them out for stealing the
show's names do our shoot show it well
confront him oh then there's probably
some Google Docs out there that we had
this idea
[Music]